welcome to this video playing zero
morale at the sky Oh Liam zero more from
from Spain from Spain again yeah lots of
spanish players really get a symmetrical
english show is going for a quickie five
that's not played and very often with
the knight on f6 due to what i'm doing
here exchanging a bishop for for the f6
night so that I have very good control
over d 5k 91 c 2 e 3 is the the normal
way to proceed i'm going to try to do
that maybe Bishop g5 was interesting but
he is not doing that okay I'm 95 and any
case he needs to spend the move for a 6b
five anyway the night is hanging rock be
one before this the additional idea of
course for white maybe I should have
played 95 before
now that I think of it it's not a big
problem but 95 before would have enabled
me to react more flexibly to this f5f
for business
I move like III can be a very useful
I sis got this ideas like I'm playing
playing f3 these are this moves ok let's
open this and I want I must get rid of
this night definitely it's not ideal but
I cannot yep because of those ideas I
cannot tolerate the night for long down
95 I will take on g2 winning winning
material so Mara ah I did I allow this
nonsense that's it's not good
very bad really
naw frustrating why does he was it like
a space again strategically out played a
couple of weeks ago and I allowed this
nonsense now everything's fine for black
man of course ah very very bad play yeah
what is this is equal material at least
I'm not a pawn down that's something at
least queen bee three queen bee three
maybe so it's a pin so i cannot take on
f3 i'm a board structure as a is a total
wreck I have to go to c7 snapped not
much choice might see seven Group D 796
look f 6 mm maybe I need to really go
back 97 look t7 will be seven rook c8
you know no trick or anything yeah
what can you do
that was really this is this is just
very bad can only hope grammy is playing
this not very very ambitious lee from
technical point of view um let's see
okay eight maybe what's the easiest way
and probably need to do this first
check
t206 book h2 kingi form hmm yeah and it
should be really enough counter plane
time morning okey 70 is my my counter
plane should be enough for draw at least
the way is playing that he can easily
loosen check check this is a shame can
you really save it like that check
really would have liked to win the game
but taking a for not love to no way to
try to play for a win right come on I'll
drown ok yeah it's it's simply it simply
it's simply awful if you really get into
trouble after a position like this is
reached because white is just just
clearly better it shouldn't matter of
precision the problem is that he I have
an eternal peace on d5 the bishop on
yourself is dead simply and my problem
was I played this far too superficially
moves like this are just not the best
and what I need to do is to put and put
something like that on the board I need
to get an e3 so that he cannot play 90
form and this is a big difference to the
game he had this 94 move and once he got
this in here he really has chances again
95 was stronger and here after after
this the situation is very tricky
already maybe I can do I can do this
what the compass should suggesting here
yeah probably probably this is this is
still good
yeah 3 looks problematic but I can just
move the bishop I it's already a bit
tricky after this and f3 this is just
this is just not good yeah it's better
to take on e 7 take 103 whether i was
already too frustrated Tim letter aloud
this yeah yeah this is just of course
clearly better home black now you played
this okay here i cannot i wanted to go
there originally but i can just do that
and gone so i needed to retreat and
after that this is possible that b5 was
also very much to be considered to just
try to win this without giving away the
beep on but this was one of this typical
instant moves that were played without
thinking much and here our look endgame
lot not so clear with the rukon e7
already this is probably not a problem
anymore around here definitely not i
tried the best but i'm also down on time
so it's it's a bit tricky to try to play
for a win okay here here i need to be
more precise okay i went at five i also
i didn't really see that look h5 is a
draw so maybe doesn't check check check
check I can ok I can try that actually
yeah but I don't have any time check or
less time ok
being wrong best I can do is probably
win the a pond somehow with Luke traded
and then it's still it wrong yeah yeah
this was really disappointing that I
played I played this Atlantis really too
quickly i didn't want to get into this
type problems again and some precise
movie i could have made my task much
easier ok thanks for watching